[Música]
vai no show falar de coisa mais conforma
que temos há 11 anos que um cérebro para
que no final do século 20
começamos a ter cuidados especiais com o
nosso corpo
começamos a correr pois aprendemos a
comer melhor e hoje corremos fazemos
esses físico e tentamos conversar vai
para ter um corpo saudável foi ficando
claro que o corpo precisa de manutenção
equidade para estar na sua melhor forma
e em relação ao cérebro em relação à
meta que cuidados é que vocês tá ném
cérebro e com o vazamento facto ter sido
mais difícil perceber que o cérebro ea
mente também precisam de uma atenção e
cuidado
damos habitualmente como certo que
competências como atenção com certeza a
pressão de sempre pressão regulação das
emoções negativas estão sempre à nossa
disposição mas podemos utilizar quando
quisermos mas na realidade não é
exatamente assim é é habitualmente
quanto mais a gente precisa
desconcentrar é quase mais aumento de
vagas somos assaltados por um pensamento
que nos distraem pega na constituição
muitas vezes o medo de falhar limita as
nossas decisões dos nossos planos e
objetivos e algumas vezes ainda deixamos
levar pela evitação a pela raiva e temos
comportamentos e dizemos coisas que
depois dos aprendemos e culpados as
nossas capacidades mentais não estão
sempre no seu melhor
quando mais precisamos delas o corpo é
como a mente ea mente é como o corpo
isto é precisa de cuidados para estar na
sua melhor forma
aquilo que o óleo é
a detenção vão ser no século 21
cuidar da mente o que fazer manutenção
da linha equivalente ao que o exercício
e alimentação foi para o corpo no século
talvez a descoberta mais excitante
neurociência seja da capacidade cerebral
se traduz na capacidade do cérebro se
modificar e desenvolver em função
daquilo que praticámos em fazemos em
termos práticos todos vocês já
perceberam isso
quanto mais se irritam com mais
facilidade ficam irritados
quanto mais culpa e criticam mais
especialistas ficam as crítica e culpa
mas também quanto mais prática uma
atenção mais capacidades que vão dizer
se concentrar mas é preciso acelerar vai
mais longe e é mesmo possível conseguir
modificações estruturais no cérebro
o marquinhos gum se usa esta capacidade
plástica do cérebro para desenvolvermos
capacidades mentais e desenvolver certas
zonas cerebrais
joão permitir ter uma vida mais
harmoniosa e mais completa
o my phone está na moda e alguns de
vocês já ouviram falar dos seus
benefícios
os benefícios do mar fornece que vocês
já conhecem eu a pontaria sobretudo dois
ou três na prevenção da corrupção
estresse a ansiedade é muito importante
para que desde a depressão mas também
para a pessoa comum na medida em que
aumenta a qualidade de vida e nos
protege do bar naughtie nos dá uma maior
flexibilidade como definições mais do
fluminense mas todas elas têm três
componentes principais desses
componentes principais
é um a um prestar atenção em ter
consciência do momento por exemplo o
fazer alguma forma intencional e fazer
um com a aceitação e c juntamente com a
arma de fogo nas e ter consciência do
que acontece na nossa vida momento
dentro e fora nós com aceitação e seus
julgamentos de forma a podermos
responder conservador iria aqui o que
acontece na nossa vida é momento eo
momento mais reservado pelas reações
automáticas do nosso cérebro facto de se
ter mostrado que algumas das nossas
fantásticas capacidades cerebrais podem
ser uma armadilha em certas situações um
pouco sobre isso que eu vou tentar
rapidamente funk
o ebay armadilha tem a ver com aquilo
que é um palavrão o exatamente negativo
do cérebro o que o que quer dizer quer
dizer que como resultado da evolução e
porque isso nos ajuda a sobreviver o
cérebro desenvolveu uma negatividade
natural que nos leva
estamos mais focados nos aspectos
negativos e merecedores de uma situação
do que nos aspectos positivos se esta
minha actividade natural no cérebro e
nos protege e nos ajudar a sobreviver em
muitas situações em que é um perigo real
há outras situações em que se pode
tornar uma armadilha
uma dessas situações é quando tentamos
tranquilizar a acertar alguma coisa que
nos preocupa no futuro por exemplo uma
doença um conflito uma reunião ou até a
simples apresentação com trabalho nessas
alturas ambiente apontando isso tudo
pode correr mal a antecipar todas as
cataratas e nunca nos tranquiliza
isto é especialmente verdade se tiverem
estresse
city eu tiver em stress e não estiverem
mais fofo né então pensamentos do tipo
não posso olhar não posso iludir
só posso descansar depois de ter feito a
fazer será conseguir estar na altura
será que vai com o rebanho
nessas alturas e pensamentos vão para
sermos tão reais que vocês pensam que
isto traduz alguma realidade acerca do
oceano da situação quando na verdade só
significam que estão stress e fato
nessas alturas é stress podemos estar a
mente está tão focada no objetivo
os pensamentos e preces são reais
podemos passar horas ou dias
atormentados por coisas que na verdade
nunca vão chegar a acontecer
quantas vezes nos aconteceu isso quantas
horas já passaram a sofrer por coisas
que na verdade nunca abuso com a prática
do mar que fornece ao nos ajudar a viver
para apresenta e ter consciência do que
me está a fazer protestos quando estamos
mais no fundo nós ficamos menos presos
das histórias que a gente constrói e que
podem limitar os nossos objetivos e os
nossos planos
isso vai ajudar a segunda armadilha que
o pensamento eo pensamento é uma
armadilha muito interessante porque
ficar sempre na nossa vida e também a
ser atendida ea capacidade cerebral que
mais nos orgulhamos e valorizar quando
focados na solução de problemas
concretos no mundo o pensamento uma
capacidade extraordinária que contribui
para os feitos notáveis da mente humana
como a arte matemática se é de 7
contudo se mantém quando você tentou
utilizar para outras situações e
situações e situações em que vocês
tentam pensar sobre
essas pressões internas negativas sobre
o episódio em que tim mas vocês próprios
quando o pensamento para tentar
controlar e evitar emoções negativas ou
até para se tranquilizarem acerca do
futuro pensar nessas alturas só vai
fazer isso por ele porque vamos ver o
pensamento construindo histórias acerca
do que somos resolução do comando é como
nos relacionamos com o trabalho como
deve ser esta tonk como é isto como é
que o tempo sempre é fazer histórias
acerca do pensamento
muitas destas histórias são úteis e
ajudamos a navegar pela vida mas quando
estas histórias são negativas
elas podem podem provocar muito
sofrimento especialmente limitadoras são
as histórias negativas centradas em
temas negativos acerca de nós próprios
então pensamentos como começou e como
devia ser como eu gostava de ser mas não
sou como é que o último veículo é que os
outros não dão valor como é que os
outros não o conhecem
será que estou à altura de fazer isto
como é que eu não sei o que os últimos
beijam
nessas alturas o pensamento é muito
limitador e vocês vêem essa limitação
acontecer em tinta que desistiu do
relacionamento de amizade ou de outros
que vivem presos dentro do mundo do
trabalho sem se permitir em descansar ou
seja fazer as suas necessidades
emocionais ou ainda quantos de vocês não
terão todo o partido a vossa
criatividade à porter saiu a falhar não
está à altura destas situações
nessas alturas o pensamento tem o seu
lado negro e seu lado luminoso do
pensamento esta capacidade de criar e
sede em encontrar soluções
o lado negro do pensamento são essas
histórias negativas criamos acerca de
nós próprios e compramos como se fosse a
realidade mas devagar
são só
porém quando conseguimos induzir alguma
distância entre nós no pensamento quando
encomendou funeso do pensamento
aprendemos a identificar os pensamentos
à medida que elas surgem na mente e ela
conhecer que eles são só pensamentos e
não é vedado à realidade das coisas
o pensamento é realidade virtual não é
as coisas nem representa as coisas
o vosso pensamento acerca da vossa mãe
não é vossa mãe é um pensamento quando a
conhecemos com o pensamento é só um
pensamento
então abrimos a porta para livre porque
o pensamento as histórias que criamos
acerca de nós em do mundo funciona
muitas vezes como uma prisão que nos
impede de ver a realidade que está aqui
quanta gente percebe muito tempo a
dissipar uma reunião o conflito com o
colega ou até a discutir com familiar na
nossa mente como se estivéssemos de fato
discutir com ele na verdade que muitas
vezes até e girinos finalmente como se
as coisas tivessem falta acontecer agora
quando conseguimos enviar para as
histórias como histórias então podemos
conhecer o pensamento é realidade
virtual que nenhum pensamento diz nada
de definitivo acerca de nós os
pensamentos
nós somos centro trás e que nem sempre
temos cruzou de ser agora como está na
moda os pensamentos muitas vezes são
feitas news
são boatos acerca do que vai acontecer
pode acontecer mas não sal
o fato era ele temos isto que nós somos
mais que os nossos pensamentos porque os
pensamentos traduzem apenas os novos
condicionamentos à forma como os nossos
pais da família o meio à cultura foi
condicionado foi programa
mandou a nossa meta é ilusão que somos
livres de pensar era um nessa o que dava
pra outra toque mas nem sempre somos
assim tão livros porque estamos muito
condicionados aos outros tipos - o tema
armadilha é o pouco tempo que tenho pra
quebrar isto mas vou tentar e apesar de
tudo conseguir responder
portanto é ideia é que de facto têm
temos nós e robôs e não observar tudo
que o nosso pensamento nos diz porque
muitas vezes é ou não é fato
e sobretudo não escolhemos a nossa
programação
não escolhemos os pais que tivermos e
toners emusa cultura em que vivemos
os programas fome zero o clima sempre
comigo tudo isso condiciona o nascimento
e quando vocês têm a ilusão que estão a
escolher nós estamos criando assim tanto
já muito estado fato provocar nossa
liberdade não é tanto o índice de
oxigênio na cabeça mas o que fazer e
como os banheiros
essa liberdade podermos escolher o que
queremos fazer com a nossa vida mais do
que reagir automaticamente aquilo que os
aparelhos feitos na nossa na regulação
das emoções negativas do facto de parar
em forma como habitualmente lidamos com
a sociedade as outras menções negativas
têm muitas vezes o efeito paradoxal e
aumentar em vez de chieming comando do
fluminense por exemplo só se estiverem
ansiosos o que é que o nascimento os dis
de imediato acaba com isso tecau marta
se tranqüilizar
mas este impulso para fugir na sociedade
vai usar a iluminação isto é ciclos
repetitivos pensamentos do tipo o que
está errado comigo porque eu me senti
assim utilizar porque o nosso como os
outros 177 que vão aumentar
ainda mais a ansiedade mas não fornece o
pensamento como fornece dez missões
abordagem do mar no fundo essas emissões
é contra intuitiva porque vai contra a
tendência natural da mente para fugir ou
evitar as emoções negativas como o
iphone aceitamos exibições e aceitaram
uma emoção é reconhecer que a missão de
contratar com ela a observar
cuidadosamente as suas manifestações no
corpo a idéia de modificar e depois que
ela desaparecer ao permitirmos que as
emissões negativa estejam em vez de
lutar contra ela
atualmente descobrimos duas coisas muito
importantes
primeiro que as emoções negativas não
durou muito
segundo que é aquilo que eventualmente
as mantenha se alimenta é nossa
tentativa de lutar contra elas e acabar
com elas e muitas vezes que mantém as
opções de tite
as ações fazem parte da nossa vida nós
podemos fugir nem nós podemos evitar
elas são fundamentais na forma como
lidamos com as circunstâncias da nossa
vida alegria tristeza raiva o medo mas
tamanha confiança e influenciam
enormemente a forma como lidamos com
nossa vida
por isso temos que aprender a estar com
as nossas impressões negativas
temos que aprender a trabalhar com elas
mas trabalhar em regular as emoções
negativas não pensa que pensar sobre
elas pensar sobre as causas mais porque
o que eu sinto isto não é fazer espaço é
prime que estejam é por exemplo várias
vezes ao longo do dia
pararmos observaremos que moção está
presente contar com ela respirar e
depois continuar com a nossa vida que é
que agora
o momento e com este presente agora que
tudo o que temos não sejam robôs
faça-o do orçamento uma amiga cuida dela
mas no fundo nessa briga
[Aplausos]